[Musique]
je m'appelle un appel pâtit gidza et je
sens cinquième année je pratique la
danse de compétition et c'est l'une de
mes passions
j'adore également la lecture de romans
et les animaux je vais vous parler de
l'évolution d'un appareil qui
tranquillement a pris de plus en plus de
place dans la vie des gens relisez
peut-être afin de ma présentation qu'il
fera plus de place qui vous le pensiez
je parlerai téléphone cellulaire
l'évolution stephen cellulaire comme
vous savez de nos jours les jeunes se
fassent à leur téléphone
en fait ce ne sont pas que les jeunes
comme prévoir il ya énormément de
téléphone sur talent en 2008 14 03
milliard de téléphones en 2009 cadac
2,64 me your et cetera en 2006 nous
avons atteint 7 2 4 milliards de
téléphones ce qui est énorme
bon je ne veux pas vous dire de ne plus
utiliser votre téléphone
je veux juste demandé de diminuer vous
apte de toujours les prendre car quand
on y pense
la moyenne de terre d'un gène sur son
téléphone environs de 4 heures par jour
en plus certaines écoles honda ehpad
c'est qu'ils augmentent leurs moyens
alors toute l'histoire commence par des
lèvres même si c'est ce ne sont pas les
chroniques cm par là que l'évolution
comme avant il n'y a pas de poste ni
courriel les gens devaient écrire des
lettres à la main qu'ils envoyaient ce
qui peut prendre plusieurs mois avant de
se rendre
comme je vous l'aï dit je n'ai pas de
poste l'agent donné leurs lettres à
quelqu'un qu'elle n'a quelqu'un d'autre
sur son chemin pour se rendre à
destination
et puis heureusement y'a invention du
téléphone en 1976 le téléphone corner en
1920 le téléphone cadrin en 1922 le
téléphone crapaud en 1960 il est
24,1 avec couleurs en 1970 le téléphone
sans fil que vous connaissez sûrement en
1990 et finalement le téléphone mobile
en 2001 vanté par martin cooper mais
vous vous dites sûrement qui a eu
d'autres choses après le téléphone
mobile et des vous avez raison
si jobs a inventé le premier téléphone
intelligent qui est sorti en janvier
aujourd'hui nous sommes rendus à la
septième version sortie en septembre
en plus selon les recherches la huitième
version pas bientôt sortir cette
personne nous allons l'appeler le iphone
alors voici une photo de quoi pourrait
ressembler le iphone est maintenant fait
pas le bon dans un futur proche selon
vous à quel point la technologie
aura-t-elle et feluy et bien selon mes
recherches à bord a développé des
appeaux glasses seront des lignes est
qui permettront de filmer et de rejouer
la vidéo sous vos yeux comme un vrai
téléphone
voici les cinq pays ayant le plus de
téléphones en commençant par la chine
avec 986 mignan l'un avec 894 millions
suivis par les états unis avec 290
l'indonésie avec 250 et finalement le
brésil avec 244 millions
les avantages et bien premièrement si
vous avez une question n'avait qu'à
l'écrire sur un site comme google ou
safari
et mme réponse va paraître très
rapidement aussi si vous cherchez des
teneurs un exemple qui vous plaît allez
chez votre ami mais vous ne savez pas
nécessairement le chemin pour vous
rendre
et bien vous n'avez qu'à écrire son
adresse sur un site comme par exemple
google maps etc ne tire et un itinéraire
très rapide et simple pas aussi vous
apparaître
vous avez la musique qui ont porté sur
plusieurs sites comme youtube fumeuses
et spotify ou tout simplement sur
l'application music les livres qui
forment en avoir plusieurs sur le même
appareil
l'appareil photo qui peux m'en prendre
une multitude sans les perdre et peut
laisser passer très facilement les
courriels et finalement et réseaux
sociaux qui vous permet de rester en
contact avec vos amis
les désavantages il ya premièrement il
ya le prix qui est très élevé pour un
simple appareil
le problème super sexy par beaucoup
d'argent dans l'argent que ton téléphone
te coûter plus les jolis livres les
applications qui s'était installée il ya
beaucoup d'argent qui perd aussi un
risque que tu n'as pas cros que témoin
d'or que tu as mon activité nerfs et
finalement ça l'ennemi n'est vraie
relation
parce que si tu fais juste chatter avec
taser avec tes amis
sipa une vraie relation parce qu'il vous
parlez pas vraiment de face en
conclusion il ya plus davantage que des
désavantages
c'est sûrement pour sa pièce populaire
mais j'aimerais quand même vous
sensibiliser au fait quel téléphone ne
remplacera jamais une vraie relation
avec vos amis maintenant une question
pour vous là votre âme et emery vaut
mieux être seul au restaurant avec votre
téléphone ou être entouré de gens que
vous aimez sans téléphone je vous laisse
penser merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]